let's make a
fresh jar of smoke the problem with old
jars is their safety buttons are popped
up everyone can tell they've been opened
but you can reverse this by sparking up
some combustion dump the flame in the
jar and the flame will turn oxygen into
other gases but the total number of
molecules in the jar will drop because
when air molecules warm up and speed up
fewer fit in the same space but they'll
lose that fast bumper car energy when
the flame goes out after we put the lid
back on now as they slow down their
smaller numbers will mean less pressure
pushing the lid up and more pressure
from the outside pushing down the safety
button is back down crushed by the
superior pressure outside also the jar
is just as hard to open now as when it
was brand new of course I'm pretending
to struggle here I wanted to show you
guys what it would look like if a normal
person tried open this jar like my
actual strength would just rip the metal
lid so I'm going to use a towel to
protect the lid from
myself there you go just like a brand
new
[Music]
jar